sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich freue mich
ja dass wir heute das bundeselterngeld
und elternzeitgesetz abschließend
beraten können das ist ein ganz
wichtiger schritt für die familien in
deutschland die erste lesung fand ja
bereits am 27 november statt vor
ziemlich genau zwei monaten und dank der
sehr konstruktiven beratungen und
berichterstatter gespräche sind wir
heute in der abschließenden lesung und
gemeinsam machen wir mit diesem gesetz
tempo für familien und stellen das
beliebte elterngeld besser und
krisenfeste auf entsetzliche ist ganz
klar wir wollen eltern dabei
unterstützen familien leben und beruf
noch besser zu vereinbaren und das
partnerschaftlich um das zu erreichen
sorgen wir mit diesem gesetz für mehr
flexibilität für weniger bürokratie und
wir kümmern uns darum dass das
partnerschaftliche prinzip und die
partnerschaftlichkeit beim elterngeld
noch mehr verstärkt wird die erhöhen
die stunden grenze für teilzeit im
elterngeld auf 24 bis 32 stunden pro
woche und ist zukünftig die ausnahme
sein dass eltern nachweise über ihre
arbeitsstunden ein rechnen müssen wenn
sie während des elterngeldbezugs in
teilzeit gearbeitet haben das erspart
eltern elterngeldstellen und in
betrieben auch jede menge bürokratie und
zudem machen wir mit diesem gesetz das
elterngeld krisenfester und stärken
damit unseren familien den rücken
so regen wir dass sich die höhe des
elterngeldes für teilzeit arbeiten
eltern nicht verändert wenn sie zum
beispiel kurzarbeitergeld oder
krankengeld erhalten denn wir wollen
nicht dass eltern die
lohnersatzleistungen beziehen auch noch
weniger elterngeld bekommen und das ist
gerade jetzt in zeiten der pandemie eine
gute nachricht wir verlängern wichtige
corona sonderreglungen die wir im
letzten frühjahr eingeführt haben bis
zum ende diesen jahres
und so müssen eltern die vier
zusätzlichen elterngeld plus monate des
partnerschafts bonus nicht zurückzahlen
wenn sie wegen der pandemie oder einer
krankheit nicht wie geplant in teilzeit
arbeiten konnten
und außerdem geschieht noch einiges was
mir sehr wichtig ist und wo ich ihnen
auf der danke als parlament wir sorgen
dafür dass eltern deren kind zu früh
geboren wird besser gestellt werden mit
dem gesetzentwurf hatten wir hatten wir
ursprünglich einen frühchen monat
vorgesehen und das parlament hat dieses
gesetz jetzt noch mal besser gemacht es
hat nämlich dafür gesorgt dass kinder
die mindestens acht wochen zu früh
geboren wurden einen weiteren
zusätzlichen elterngeld im monat
bekommen also zwei monate wird das kind
zwölf wochen zu früh geboren gibt es
drei zusätzliche elterngeld monate und
wenn ihr kind 16 wochen zu früh geboren
wird dann gibt es sogar vier zusätzliche
elterngeld monate und damit wird der
tatsache rechnung getragen dass wir eben
einen großen unterschied sehen ob ein
kind sechs wochen oder 16 wochen zu früh
geboren würden ist es eine gute
entscheidung dass es so verabredet und
vereinbart worden ist und dafür möchte
ich ihnen sehr herzlich danken hier im
keim
das haben sie erreicht herzlichen dank
dafür meine damen und herren mit diesem
gesetz machen wir das elterngeld
partnerschaftlicher flexibler
unbürokratischer und wir stärken und
familien in unserem land mit der
bekanntesten und beliebtesten
familienleistungen deutschland über 7
milliarden euro geben wir jedes jahr
dafür aus die elterngeld reform ist ein
bestandteil ein baustein unserer
modernen familienpolitik eine politik
die die interessen und bedürfnisse der
eltern und der familien in den
mittelpunkt stellt und deshalb ist ein
gutes zeichen gerade in der krise und
deshalb vielen herzlichen dank für ihre
unterstützung
das ist der bundesfamilienministerin
sagt partnerschaftlicher und flexibler
werde das bundeselterngeld und die
elternzeit jedenfalls die regelungen
dazu mit der gesetzesänderung die hier
heute abschließend beraten wird wir
können vermuten dass kathrin werner die
die nächste rednerin ist so und
sprecherin für familien und senioren
politik der linksfraktion dadurch den
ein oder anderen punkt jetzt höre ich
gerade ist hat eine verschiebung gegeben
ich hatte hier eine andere information
denn nicht so redner ist johannes huber
aus der fdp-fraktion per du
sehr geehrter herr präsident herr liebe
landsleute
der gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
zum elterngeld es kein großer wurf
sondern eher ein mageres herumdoktern an
einem system das einer grundlegenden
reform bedarf der positivste aspekt des
gesetzes ist noch dass die problematik
bei frühchen tatsächlich angegangen wird
die geplante lösung überzeugt aber nicht
komplett um nämlich die medizinische die
notwendige versorgung frühgeborener zu
berücksichtigen haben wir als afd sogar
die empfehlung des bundesrates auf
unserer seite wenn wir sagen dass das
elterngeld ab entlassung des kindes aus
dem krankenhaus beginnen soll
beim bezug von elterngeld plus
verschlechterte gesetzentwurf sogar die
bisherige lage der eltern mit der neuen
regelung können eltern nur bis zum 32
lebensmonat eltern beziehen statt wie
bisher bis zum 48 monat hier muss man
zwangsläufig feststellen dass die
regierung nicht nur ihren eigenen
anspruch der flexibilisierung
konterkarierte sondern sogar bewusst an
den eltern sparen will und einen
ersatzlosen verfall der
familienleistungen billigend in kauf
nimmt
2007 hatte die damalige bundesregierung
die einführung des elterngeldes noch mit
der extrem niedrigen geburtenrate und
der wahlfreiheit zwischen den
verschiedenen lebensentwürfen begründet
davon ist heute nicht mehr viel übrig
anstatt für eine moderne aktivierende
familienpolitik geld in die hand zu
nehmen um die demografische krise auch
zu überwinden betreibt das spd geführte
ministerium heute viel mehr ideologische
gleichstellung der partnerschafts bonus
zwar rhetorisch gut geträumt aber es
besteht hier keine chancengleichheit
unter den familienmodellen mit den
zusätzlichen bonus monaten
werden nämlich zum beispiel doppel ist
china pärchen im öffentlichen dienst mit
einem kind belohnt werden selbstständige
sich schwer damit tun volle 12 monate in
elternzeit zu gehen
und was ist eigentlich mit den eltern
die mehrere kinder haben sie leben
meistens das alleinverdiener oder zu
verdienen modell denn mit mehr kindern
fällt auch mehr familienarbeit an die
regierung speist diese eltern mit 150
euro für 24 monate ab das greift
eindeutig in die elterliche wahlfreiheit
ein und hat nichts mehr mit der
verfassungsrechtlich gebotene
neutralität des staates gegenüber den
unterschiedlichen familienmodellen zu
tun
daher fordern wir statt einem egalitären
umbau der familie eine
gleichberechtigung aller modelle und das
geht am besten mit einer erhöhung der
bezugsdauer von 12 auf 18 monate basis
elterngeld bzw 36 monate elterngeld plus
für alle modelle also auch für die
traditionelle familie für gefallen um
darüber hinaus eine bessere
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf zu
erreichen müsste aber unbedingt auch die
höhe des elterngeldes angepasst werden
die jetzige berechnung des elterngeldes
passiert nämlich auf einer statistik von
was zeigt das elterngeld wurde real seit
35 jahren nicht erhöht war der
mindestbetrag der einführung des
elterngeldes noch vom damaligen
steuerfrei zu stellen existenzminimum
abgedeckt so müsste dieser
entsprechenden bericht der
bundesregierung im kommenden jahr statt
derzeit 300 euro 455 euro betragen
analog auch für einen mehr links
zuschlag
die bundesregierung hat aber bis heute
eine überfällige anpassung versäumt und
es besteht dringender handlungsbedarf um
den schleichenden sozialabbau in unseren
familien mit einer jährlichen anpassung
entgegenzutreten
sowohl der höchstbetrag als auch die
politisch festgelegte geringverdiener
grenze müssten unter berücksichtigung
der beitragsbemessungsgrenze ebenfalls
um 36 prozent erhöht werden
denn nur mit einer erhöhung des mindest
und des höchstbetrages können wir wahre
finanzielle sicherheit für alle familien
schaffen und es im übrigen auch den
vätern ermöglichen mehr zeit mit den
eigenen kindern zu verbringen
[Applaus]
johannes huber war das für die
fdp-fraktion mitglied im ausschuss für
familie senioren frauen und jugend und
jetzt kommt mir schon vorher
angekündigte katrin werner bekommt ihr
auch nicht also wir haben ja eine
warteliste vorliegen deswegen erzähle
ich hier dummes zeug das gefällt mir
nicht aber nix für ungut nadine schulden
aus der unionsfraktion stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende dort sehr geehrter
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir schließen heute die elterngeld zu
form ab das elterngeld ist eine der
beliebtesten leistungen für familien in
unserem land das elterngeld und die
elternzeit ist bisher schon sehr gut
gewesen
der gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
hat es noch mal verbessert und wir im
parlamentarischen verfahren haben das
was gut war und verbessert werden sollte
noch einmal mehr verbessert und das ist
ein gutes signal an die eltern und 30
ein in eine ganze menge anderer
maßnahmen die wir in dieser
legislaturperiode für familien gemacht
haben elterngeld und elternzeit das ist
das paradebeispiel christdemokratischer
familienpolitik denn wir schaffen damit
zeit für familien
wir ermöglichen die finanzielle
unterstützen und für ermöglichen
wahlfreiheit
das elterngeld zeichnet sich dadurch aus
dass es sehr flexibel ist es gibt
unglaublich viele möglichkeiten wie pade
die erziehung und betreuung ihrer kinder
mit der berufstätigkeit verbinden können
und das machen wir mit diesem
gesetzentwurf noch ein stück flexibler
bisher musste man elterngeld beim bezug
von elterngeld plus zwischen 25 und 30
stunden arbeiten diesen korridor passen
wir an auf 24 bis 22 32 stunden und das
passt besser zu einer normalen acht
stunden zeit
bisher mussten beide partner vier monate
parallel in teilzeit arbeiten und
partnerschafts monate zu bekommen auch
das ändern wir künftig kann man wählen
zwischen einem und vier monate und
parallel dazu machen wir es auch noch
bequemer wir haben vor kurzem einen
gesetzentwurf verabschiedet oder ein
gesetz verabschiedet wo wir die
digitalisierung des elterngeld ist
beschlossen haben
und wenn das umgesetzt wird wird es
künftig ganz einfach möglich sein
von der couch aus das elterngeld zu
beantragen sich zu informieren den
antrag zu stellen medienbruchfrei alles
von der couch aus ganz bequem und es
freut mich sehr dass wir im
parlamentarischen verfahren verschiedene
dinge verbessern konnten ganz besonders
am herzen liegt mir die regelung zu den
flüchen die zeit die ein baby im bauch
nicht hatte braucht es auf der welt hin
zu mehr die kleinen kämpfer haben es in
den ersten monaten besonders schwer
sie brauchen mehr zeit um den gleichen
entwicklungsstand zu erreichen wie
kinder die wie geplant zur welt bekommen
sind sie brauchen noch mehr pflege
fürsorge zuwendung unterstützung man
schon auch noch mehr ärztliche und
therapeutische hilfe und das kostet auch
für die eltern viel kraft und zeit und
deshalb werden wir das künftig so machen
dass ein kind das sechs wochen zu früh
gekommen ist der den eltern haben einen
elterngeld monat mehr acht wochen sind
es zwei elterngeld monate mehr
ab zwölf wochen drei elterngeld monate
mehr und bei 16 wochen sind es vier
elterngeld monate mehr
das ist eine kleine unterstützung für
diese familien in dieser schweren zeit
dass sie mehr zeit für die kinder haben
mehr zeit für unterstützung für
zuwendung und um die
entwicklungsrückstände die für geborene
kinder einfach haben besser aufhören zu
können
und das bereitet die cologne akquise für
familien eine besondere belastung ist
das sehen wir ja alle jeden tag und das
können wir leider auch nicht komplett
abfedern so ehrlich müssen wir sein aber
wir versuchen wenigstens die
finanziellen einbußen zu schmieden
schmälern so auch beim elterngeld wir
haben hier schon verschiedene maßnahmen
auf den weg gebracht etwa dass die der
bezug von kurzarbeitergeld nicht rein
schlägt bei der berechnung des
elterngeldes wir haben jetzt die
regelung des partnerschafts bohnen der
partnerschafts bonus monate werden wir
verlängern und auch die teilweise nicht
anrechnung des elterngelds auf
ersatzleistungen wie das
kurzarbeitergeld um das krankengeld
verändern wir und wir haben hier gerade
in der krise gesehen dass das ein bedarf
es nicht nur in krisenzeiten haben
das machen wir auch für regelungen
außerhalb der krise
ich finde es ist ein guter gesetzentwurf
der sich einreiht in eine ganze an
weitere menge von maßnahmen sei es
kindergeld kinderzuschlag
alleinerziehenden zuschlag
alleinerziehenden frei bezahlt das
baukindergeld kollegen viele weitere
maßnahmen und deshalb ist das eine gute
ding statur periode für familien und
dass hier ein weiterer wichtiger
baustein der den schön weil das für die
unionsfraktion wo sie stellvertretende
vorsitzende ist und die haben uns jetzt
mal schlau gemacht wie denn hier die
reihenfolge bei den rednern tatsächliche
sturm hat uns gesagt denn ich so redner
sei gregorio es aus der fdp-fraktion wo
er familienpolitischer sprecher ist aber
es gibt ein
von den kollegen krieges angeht ist aber
es ist sogar diesmal
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte frau ministerin nach zwei jahren
endlich die lang avisierte und
überfällige reform des elterngeldes und
die jetzige vorlage zeigt aus meiner
sicht aus unserer überzeugung wie
wichtig es ist wie wichtig unser
parlamentarismus wirkt und wie sehr
debatten prägen können und auch
verbesserungen durchführen und wie sehr
auch eben eine konsequente
oppositionsarbeit wirkt immer wieder
habe ich auch hier festgestellt was es
für notwendige verbesserungen hier gibt
und deswegen freuen wir uns freue ich
mich ganz besonders dass zu den
positiven aspekten die sie übernommen
haben wir hier einige beispiele nennen
können sie haben oder wir haben wir
freuen uns sehr darüber dass wir endlich
ist durch gekriegt haben dass sie
übernehmen
dass es für die frühchen eine bessere
regelung geben soll als so wie sie es
bisher war und ich danke da im zweifel
besonders auch die cdu die unsere
anregungen übernommen hat das ist eine
gute lösung auch dass sie die
arbeitszeit korridore angepasst haben
dass sie bei den partnerschafts monaten
entsprechend flexibilisiert haben all
das sind dinge die wir begrüßen und hier
begrüßen auch sehr dass sie die
anrechnung was das thema
lohnersatzleistung angeht an das
elterngeld verbessert haben
[Applaus]
insgesamt fehlt aber entscheidendes auch
wenn es ein besserer entwurf es jetzt
durch das parlament denn entscheiden das
packen sie wieder nicht an wieder beim
krankengeld noch beim insolvenz geht
oder beim kurzarbeitergeld wird die
werden nicht voll beim elterngeld bei
der berechnung des elterngeldanspruchs
berechnet oder berücksichtigt und genau
das fordern wir damit familien
vorausschauend auch in den kommenden
krisen oder kommenden krisensituationen
finanzielle sicherheit haben darüber
hinaus verlängern oder möchten wir dass
gerade jetzt in der prämie wenn man sich
anguckt wie sehr die familien unter
druck geraten wenn man sich anguckt wie
das mit kita schließungen aussieht das
ist eine verlängerung des elterngeldes
gibt wenn keine eingewöhnung möglich ist
oder diese eingewöhnung deutlich länger
dauert diese verlängerung beim
elterngeld haben wir beantragt bitte
folgen sie dem und auch die viel zu
lange bearbeitungsdauer wird nicht durch
die digitalisierung des elterngeld
antrags verbessert sondern viel zu lange
müssen familien monatelang auf ihr geld
warten
auch da fordern wir schaffen sie über
eine digitalisierte auch bearbeitung der
entsprechende geschwindigkeit und
ermöglichst es abschlagszahlung zu
machen oder beziehungsweise den antrag
haben wir vorgelegt damit älter hunter
mit familie neben schnellstmöglich zu
ihrem geld kommen und nicht monatelang
faden
und da sie ja gerade darüber gesprochen
haben das hier ist familien gibt die
besonders unterstützung brauchen wir
fordern
geben sie die möglichkeit das ist auch
unser antrag pflegefamilien pflegeeltern
dass sie auch das elterngeld
beanspruchen können das brauche diese
familien das brauchen diese eltern und
vor allem brauchen das und tut es den
pflegekindern gut meine damen und herren
und deswegen während gerade diese
änderung unter anderem die wir
vorgeschlagen haben und die wir auf den
tisch gelegt haben gerade in dieser
pandemie zeit so unglaublich wichtig
eine bessere und vorausschauende eltern
geht reform herkunft achten eltern
hoffen sie redet zeit abgelaufen
selbst ersatz der präsident so und
deswegen geht auch heute 1 wer gute
familienpolitik w muss freidemokraten
wählen weil wir die besten lösungen in
diesem bereich haben danke gregorius
aggelidis für die fdp-fraktion dort
familienpolitischer sprecher und ich
unter nehmen wir mal einen weiteren
anlauf katrin werner anzukündigen aus
der linksfraktion wo sie sprecherin für
familien und senioren politik ist und
tatsächlich sie steht auch schon und ist
auf dem weg zum pol
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident der geehrte
damen und herren wir beraten
abschließend über den gesetzentwurf zur
änderung des elterngeldes unter
elternzeit ja der bezug von elterngeld
soll etwas flexibler werden die
möglichkeiten zur teilzeit werden ein
wenig besser und es soll einfacher
werden den partnerschafts bonus zu
erhalten
auch werden eltern von frühgeborenen
kindern besser unterstützt nach großer
kritik in der anhörung hat die große
koalition sich sogar zu einer besseren
früh geboten regung durchringen können
das sind alles
in die richtige richtung aber vor
gefallen auch wenn sie sagen reform
wir sagen wieder nur es ist ein
gefährlichen was ist mit der besseren
unterstützung von ärmeren vernehmen
was sind wo sind die mutigen schritte zu
mehr partnerschaftlichkeit jahre lang
wurden die großen probleme für viele
familien liegen gelassen und wir finden
die baustellen in den letzten jahren
sind größer geworden und wissen ich will
einfach mal ein bild machen
jeder weiß auf großen baustellen darauf
große bagger um schnell voranzukommen
und folge dir manchmal das gefühl sie
sitzen mit ihrem schäufelchen im
sandkasten
so werden wir nie fertig so kommen wir
nicht schnell voran
wir alle wissen die korona krise hat zu
einem enormen mehrbelastung von familien
geführt es ist hat sich gezeigt dass die
traditionellen rollen und
aufgabenverteilung zwischen männer und
frauen zementiert wurden immer noch
übernehmen vorwiegend frauen die haus
sorge und erziehungsarbeit jetzt kommt
homeschooling dazu setzt sie vor
gefeiert haben am mittwoch darauf
hingewiesen in der regierungsbefragung
und es ist jetzt an der zeit maßnahmen
für eine gerechtere aufteilung der
sorgearbeit von familie zu fördern
die linke fordert 12 monate elterngeld
hoch eltern kann und was nicht
übertragbar für alleinerziehende 24
monate und es ist jetzt an der zeit für
mehr partnerschaftlichkeit eine weitere
baustelle beim elterngeld liegt
vollkommen brach die bessere
unterstützung von ärmeren familien sieht
zieht die bundesregierung nicht einmal
in betracht 2007 wurde das elterngeld
eingeführt 14 jahre 14 jahre liegt der
beitrag bei 300 euro keine stellung
die linke sagt das muss sich ändern und
zwar jetzt mindestens 400 auf 400 euro
muss er angehoben werden und sollte
jährlich steigen so wie auch die
verbraucherpreise steigen
bei menschheit hier wird das elterngeld
ab sogar angerechnet sie gehen also
komplett leer aus
die familien die es am dringendsten
benötigen werden wieder ausgeschlossen
und da sagen wir das darf nicht sein so
lange wir keine kinder grundsicherung
haben muss die anrechnung von elterngeld
auf hat sie abgeschafft werden und es
ist jetzt zeit für einen sozialen aufruf
benachteilige wir müssen stärker in den
blick genommen werden und solidarität
muss stark gemacht werden
und ich sagte wie beim letzten mal bei
nicht jetzt wann dann stimmen sie unsere
man kriege zu das wäre ein guter anfang
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt heißt es worte kollegin ekin
deligöz bündnis 90/die grünen und ich
den blick es ist kinder und
familienpolitische sprecherin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ja das
was wir heute beschließen im bereich des
elterngelds das ist ein wichtiger und
auch ein notwendiger schritt aber der
große wurf ist es nicht sie sind sehr
klein klein in dem was sie machen und
was nicht wirklich am meisten ärgert hat
meine kollegin von den linken auch
gesagt wir schaffen mit dem elterngeld
ein schonraum für eltern gerade wenn die
jungen babys auf der welt sind
diesen schonraum gestehen wir mit einem
300 euro basis geld auf menschen zu die
zu hause also hausfrauen zu und männer
die zu hause sind aber bei hartz4
rechnen wir das an das heißt für
menschen die grundsicherung sind sagen
wir ihr habt kein schonraum warum nicht
warum nicht ich verstehe das nicht wenn
wir keine eltern zukommen lassen sollten
sollten wir da nicht unterscheiden ob es
die menschen in grundsicherung sind oder
nicht das zweite ist sie reden über
flexibilisierung aber sie machen nicht
nur wirklich eine echte flexibilisierung
eine mutige flexibilisierung würde sagen
es gibt zeiten und kinder ihre eltern
brauchen manchmal ist es auch das erste
schuljahr das ist dieser übergang vom
kindergarten in die schule ist eine sehr
fragile lage und warum sollten dein
vater mutter nicht mal sechs monate zu
hause bleiben um das kind in dieser
phase begleiten kann
wenn wir das den eltern zugestehen
würden wir ihnen mehr vertrauen
entgegenbringen und sie wirklich
unterstützung und das wäre eine
flexibilisierung das den namen auch
verdient
oder lassen sie uns über die partner
komponente reden nur dass ich alle
zweifel hier aufhebe ja ich will
der anreiz für väter ich will dass väter
sich an der erziehung beteiligen können
möglichst gut deshalb schlagen wir vor
88 88 85 a 8 zu gemeinsamen verfügung
eine echte paritätische aufteilung das
wäre doch unser ziel und nicht ein
bisschen und ein paar tage und und meint
wir schwächen die familien nicht wenn
ich den zwischenruf aufnehmen kann wir
stärken die familien viele väter wollen
ihren kindern nicht mehr aus der ferne
zuschauen
sie wollen mit ihren kindern gemeinsam
zeit verbringen sie wollen nicht mehr
die kinder nur abstellen und will die
väter das wollen sollten wir ihnen das
auch genehmigen
ihr lebensmodell ist schon lange vorbei
in deutschland das ist schon lange
vorbei
die neuen familien ticken anders als sie
um gott sei dank ist es auch so weil
auch kinder ihre väter brauchen
ausrufezeichen und das letzte jahr
selbstständige und pflegetag auch da
müssen wir noch mal den blick hinein
werfen bald auch da brauchen wir eine
stärkere unterstützung gerade bei den
pflegeeltern sie können zwar elterngeld
in anspruch nehmen aber nur wenn es
kleinkinder sind was ist aber wenn ich
ein älteres pflegekind bekomme dann
bekomme ich nicht aber gerade da gerade
in so einer schwierigen situation
brauche ich auch zeit und raum für
dieses kind und deshalb brauchen wir
hier eine echte reform genau für diese
menschen die in diesem land etwas gutes
tun um sie zu unterstützen
wir sollten eltern vertrauen wir sollten
in diesem vertrauen ihnen auch mehr
flexibilität gewähren
diego ist die kinder- und
familienpolitische sprecherin der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen in der
beratung des bundeselterngeld- und
elternzeitgesetz beziehungsweise dessen
veränderungen und reformen es gibt ja
eine ganze menge kleinerer schritte und
auch größerer die das ganze voranbringen
sollen und familien das leben leichter
machen sollen insbesondere in der
frühphase von irgendeinem kleinen cain
wieder an stefan schwartze ist der
nächste redner aus der spd-fraktion
liegt meine damen und herren liebe
eltern und die es noch werden wollen
das elterngeld ist seit seiner
einführung 2007 eine erfolgsgeschichte
flexibilisierung vereinfachung und
verbesserung darum geht es heute immer
mehr junge eltern nutzten die
möglichkeiten durch das elterngeld mehr
zeit für die familie zu haben
arbeits und familienzeit
gleichberechtigt untereinander
aufzuteilen
genau das ist der wunsch der familien
der erfolg ist aber auch ein auftrag die
regelung immer wieder den umständen
bedürfnissen und wünschen anzupassen wie
wir das auch in ganz besonderer weise in
dieser corona krise immer wieder tun wie
wir heute das elterngeld insgesamt
weiter entwickeln ich danke ministerin
franziska gefallen für ihren guten
entwurf und ich danke dem
koalitionspartner für die schnelle
konstruktive beratung in denen wir noch
wichtige dinge für die eltern erreichen
konnten
auch drei wichtige änderungen möchte ich
kurz eingehen
beim partnerschaft bonus sind wir all
die dinge angegangen die eltern bisher
davon abgehalten haben ihn zu nehmen
so erweitern wir den stunden korridor
auf 24 bis 32 stunden teilzeitarbeit das
ist lebensnah
denn jetzt sind eine drei oder vier tage
woche möglich es wird also flexibler und
einfacher
wir haben aus der krise gelernt und
sorgen dafür dass kurzarbeit oder
krankengeld sich nicht mehr negativ
auswirken
eine regelung die wir hier in
im bereich auf dauer übernehmen wenn ein
kind zu früh auf die welt kommt ist dies
für eltern und kind oft eine riesige
herausforderung
deswegen führen wir eine neue regelung
für diese familien in das elterngeld ein
deswegen werden wir diese familien
länger unterstützen bin froh dass wir in
dieser stelle noch einmal verbesserungen
für die familien erreichen konnten das
lag uns gemeinsam wirklich am herzen
künftig wird es gestaffelt je nachdem ob
das kind 68 12 oder 16 wochen zu früh
geboren wurde je einen weiteren monat
elterngeld geben
diese regelung gibt den familien zeit
zeit die sie dringend benötigen
und als dritten punkt möchte ich auch
die neuregelung für die kleine
selbstständigkeit für mich einkünfte
hinweisen
insbesondere auch ehrenamtliche mit
kleine aufwandsentschädigung profitieren
von diesen änderungen
das elterngeld wird sich immer
weiterentwickeln in der nächsten
legislaturperiode werden wir sicherlich
über die höhe des elterngelds sprechen
müssen und auch darüber ob wir
pflegeeltern in den elterngeldbezug mit
aufnehmen flexibilisierung vereinfachung
verbesserung machen das elterngeld noch
attraktiver oder wie wir in ostwestfalen
sagen da kannst du nichts von sagen
stefan schwartze noch mit rapper
gepflogenheiten aus dem ostwestfälischen
und damit kommen wir schon zur
vorletzten reden zum vorletzten redner
pardon in dieser debatte um diese
aussprache zum bundeselterngeld und
elternzeitgesetz beziehungsweise dessen
änderungen das ist der mann aus der
unionsfraktion kolleginnen kollegen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
vielleicht was gab stimmt und es hat
sich schon so sagen gewöhnt vielleicht
kurz vorweg wir befinden uns heute in
der kern debatte des deutschen
bundestages und wir sagen immer familien
gehören auch zum kernstück unserer
gesellschaft deswegen freue mich
besonders dass wir gleich zwei
familienpolitische themen heute morgen
auch in der kernzeit diskutieren ich
finde da gehören sie auch hin
wir haben jetzt auch schon viel zu dem
gesetzentwurf zu der verbesserung des
elterngeldes gehört es ja wohl ist es
eine erfolgsgeschichte als das 2007 von
frau von der leyen hier eingebracht
wurde
das mit vier milliarden euro gestartet
jetzt sind wir bei über 7 milliarden bin
mir sicher wir werden in diesem jahr
sicherlich noch an die acht milliarden
kommen das heißt das ist etwas was wir
für familien ganz konkret auch zur
verfügung stellen
man kann das nicht immer so klein reden
und wissen sie was auch spannend ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
eigentlich stellen sich heute alle
kollegen auch ans rednerpult und sagen
dass die dinge die jetzt mit diesem
gesetz verändert und verbessert werden
ganz okay und ganz gut sind
mehr geht immer mehr geht immer
und deswegen weil sich eigentlich auch
alle auch von der opposition gesagt
haben dass das was wir jetzt machen gut
ist können sie sowohl dem gesetzentwurf
als auch den änderungsantrag zum stimm
ich lade sie dazu auf jeden fall
herzlich ein
aber jetzt auch noch mal was vielleicht
zu den kosten damit man das mal so ein
bisschen auch sich zu gemüte führen kann
hier wird er gefordert das
mindestelterngeld zu erhöhen ja das ist
sicherlich ein punkt über den wir
diskutieren müssen das tun wir dann auch
sicherlich in der nächsten legislatur
aber nun mal so die anhebung des
elterngeldes mindest elterngeldes auf
350 euro im monat kostet 160 millionen
im jahr auf 400 euro im monat kostet 290
millionen im jahr
und wenn ich die höchstgrenze auf 2100
euro erhöhe sind es nochmals monaten
millionen euro im jahr
wir haben aber hier die aufgabe gehabt
diese veränderung aus dem eigenen etat
des hauses zu bestreiten und da sind die
mittel begrenzt und ich finde mit den
begrenzten mitteln die wir hatten haben
wir wirklich viel auf den weg gebracht
und dann wird ihr auch immer
hervorgehoben und auch darüber muss man
dann vielleicht irgendwann diskutieren
dass man oder dass das elterngeld nicht
auf die grundsicherung oder auch
sozialleistungen angerechnet werden soll
die anhebung oder die die anrechnung des
elterngeldes auch sozialleistungen trägt
aber ja dem umstand rechnung dass der
bedarf der eltern und der kinder im
system der grundsicherung durch die
regelsätze und die zusatzleistungen dort
bereits gesichert ist auch das gehört zu
weit dazu das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
bei der debatte liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich freue mich aber ganz
besonders weil es eben der tatsächlich
eine herzensangelegenheit von mir bei
meinen kollegen und kollegen sind schon
auf die punkte eingegangen
aber die frühchen regelungen die möchte
ich auch nochmal erwähnen weil diese
regelung dass man eben ein elterngeld
monat mehr bekommt wenn ein kind sechs
wochen zu früh geboren wurde
das hat ja auch einen medizinischen
grund weil ein frühchen ist ein frühchen
wenn es mindestens sechs wochen zu früh
geboren ist und danach lehnt machen wir
einfach weiter mit der anlehnung monats
gerecht acht wochen zwei monate mehr
zwölf wochen drei monate mehr 16 wochen
der monate ich glaube das ist eine gute
regelung wo wir vielen eltern eben auch
mit unterstützen und auch das sind 20
bis 25 millionen euro im jahr
das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich finde
wir haben mit den begrenzten mitteln die
wir haben ein gutes verhältnis gesetz
noch besser gemacht deswegen bitte ich
um zustimmung und laden alle herzlich
dazu ein vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und der hermann aus der
unionsfraktion war der vorletzte redner
in dieser aussprache und hat zu beginn
auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass er
gleich im anschluss an diesen
tagesordnungspunkt ein weiteres
familienpolitisches gesetzesvorhaben auf
der agenda steht der dialog kinder und
jugend stärkung aber jetzt erst noch mal
silke laune
für die unionsfraktion und wie gesagt
letzte rednerin zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir können
wir junge mütter dabei unterstützen dass
sie nach der geburt des kindes
vielleicht auch beruflich den anschluss
nicht verlieren sich sogar
weiterentwickeln können ihr potenzial
entfalten können wenn sie das wollen
wie können wir junge eltern mehr
partnerschaftliche teilhabe ermöglichen
wenn sie das wollen
ja und wie können wir eltern von
frühchen helfen die herausforderungen
die entstehen wenn ein kind deutlich zu
früh geboren wird besser zu meistern
wir haben uns diese fragen gestellt nach
antworten gesucht und wir haben auch
welche gefunden
ein ganzes bündel an maßnahmen mit
diesen maßnahmen wollen wir die
situation von jungen eltern verbessern
und dabei haben wir auch viele
anregungen die aus der praxis gekommen
sind mit einbezogen mehr flexibilität
war ein wunsch der partnerschaftliche
teilhabe war ein wunsch und vor allem
eine bessere vereinbarkeit von familie
und beruf
da sind die kernelemente die
grundpfeiler unserer reform und sie
wurden im einzelnen schon angesprochen
aber ich möchte sie auch nochmal
ansprechen
selbst im zug aber insgesamt mehrfach
hatten mich ein vater darauf
angesprochen er würde ja so gerne sich
beteiligen auch elterngeld monate nehmen
oder den partnerschafts bonus oder
elternzeit für ihn wäre es möglich eine
vier tages woche aber 30 stunden bis
schwierig mit seinem arbeitgeber das
ermöglichen wir jetzt warum weil die
höchstarbeitszeit grenze für die dauer
des elterngeldbezugs und während der
elternzeit von 30 auf 32 wochenstunden
erhöhen das heißt auch da ist führt die
elternteile mutter oder vater die das
wollen zumindest eine vier-tage-woche
möglich sehr viele arbeitgeber sind da
oft auch kulant zu sagen okay der
freitag nicht aber diese vier tage woche
biete ich dir an
dadurch können auch väter die dann
stärke die partnerschafts bonus nutzen
wollen mehr davon profitieren man kann
sich aufteilen
der rahmen wurde auch hier verändert
stunden korridor von 24 bis 32
wochenstunden das heißt zum beispiel
kann auch andersrum sein die frau
arbeitet drei tage die woche der mann
vier tage die woche
man hat vielleicht noch großeltern im
hintergrund die zwei tage die woche
abdecken also wir ermöglichen hier mehr
flexibilität und das passiert auf den
wünschen vieler eltern die bezugsdauer
ist flexibler und natürlich dass eines
der wichtigsten anliegen wir nehmen die
eltern im blick und die kinder die es
zum start in ein neues familien leben
besonders schwer hatten die kinder die
zu früh geboren sind da gibt es
besonders viele sorgen ängste nöte
unsicherheiten die kann ein parlament
den eltern nicht nehmen aber wir können
ihnen etwas zeit geben zeit die verloren
gegangen ist
zeit die die eltern brauchen um sich nur
einzustellen und zeit die das kind
benötigt um entwicklungsverzögerungen
auszugleichen
und deshalb begrüße ich diese neue
regelung sehr sie wurde schon erwähnt
sechs wochen vorher ein monat extra acht
wochen vorher zwei basis elterngeld
monate extra ab zwölf wochen drei und ab
16 4
leider gelingt dem schon deshalb muss
ich zum schluss kommen wir würden uns
von der csu auch gerne noch zwei weitere
monate für die väter wünschen weil wir
diesen drei wünschen flexibilität
partnerschaftliche teilhabe bessere
vereinbarkeit von familie weil uns diese
drei wünsche sehr richtig sind und wir
die gerne mit ihnen in der zukunft
weiter verwirklichen werden
[Applaus]